[Musique]
monumental de battre Magnus Carsen dans
deux matchs consécutifs en grande finale
de lakeup notre Tricolore avait une
revanche à prendre puis c'était incliné
deux jours auparavant au final du
tableau des gagnants après un match
épique où il avait fini par être
terrassé seulement à l'Armageddon Maxime
avait ensuite battu une peau net et sans
bavure de à zéro dans la consolante pour
donc gagner le droit de réaffronter car
c'est cette fois en grande finale
néanmoins sa mission annoncée
herculéenne puisqu'il devait donc
l'emporter une première fois dans un
match au meilleur des quatre parties
pour remettre les compteurs à zéro puis
si les parvenait donc s'imposer cette
fois dans un match en deux parties nous
allons revenir ensemble sur les moments
forts de cette exploit du Tricolore
alors maxime a d'abord annoncé la
couleur dès la première joute avec les
pièces noires où il a joué final dans
son style il a pas hésité à sacrifier un
pion pour obtenir des compensation et la
paire de fou les deux joueurs en jeu de
manière extrêmement précise et on
obtient cette position cette finale ou
donc avec les pièces noires un pion de
moins mais la paire de fou ici Carsen a
fait un premier choix peut-être un peu
douteux il a joué fou des 6 alors qu'il
aurait pu simplement jouer fou E5 pour
assurer de prendre aucun risque sécurisé
donc ce pion des 4 et si la nul était
vraiment le résultat la plus probable
quand même avec les Blancs c'est une
nouvelle pu mettre une petite pression
en comptant sur son sur son pion B mais
normalement ici la paire de fou devrait
compenser et Maxime s'en sortir à la
place car ça n'a joué fou des 6
permettant un Maxime de simplifier de
récupérer son pion de retard alors
évidemment norvégien il a pas fait ça au
hasard son plan c'était d'envoyer son
pion B passer éloigné sauf que ça s'est
retourné contre lui on va passer
rapidement et on va réaliser que ce pion
B c'est à dire une faiblesse plutôt
qu'une force donc je joue les coups un
peu vides juste pour arriver au moment
critique on voit que maintenant il est
sur une case blanche et donc il va être
facilement attaquable par le roi et
indéfendable donc ici
Maxime va gagner le pion normalement un
jeu précis les blancs ici peuvent encore
s'en sortir mais ils ont quand même des
pions sur case noire faible doublés et
avec le peu de temps la pendule c'est
très compliqué et car c'est une a pensé
pouvoir forcer la nul en jouant un roi
E4 mais c'est un mauvais calcul de ça
part maxime a pris le pion et ensuite
fait preuve d'une technique chirurgicale
vous allez voir c'est impressionnant il
a été capturé le plombé 5 avance de
nouveau un peu rapide alors juste pour
expliquer l'idée de car scène c'était
certainement de sacrifier son fou en
espérant à la fin dire qu'on a une
forteresse avec les fameuses finales
juste pour illustrer je joins un coup
droit avec une finale avec le fou donc
de la mauvaise couleur qui contrôle pas
la case d'arrivée du pion donc de ce
pion h auquel cas ça pourrait faire nul
sauf que pour plusieurs raisons ce n'est
pas le cas mais plus simplement Maxime
il lui a ici infligé une douche froide
en jouant le bon coup H4
et l'idée donc c'est qu'il défend son
pion tout simplement et donc il empêche
tous les sacrifices cette finale est
maintenant gagnante mais c'est pas si
facile puisque le roi blanc est très
actif et on va encore une fois avancer
jusqu'à la partie maxime a compris qu'il
n'avait besoin que d'un pion pour
l'emporter son pion F qui l'envoie avec
force derrière le four blanc va tenter
d'arrêter le pion mais Maxime va nous
faire des petites manœuvres et seulement
en 10 secondes à la pendule ici ou le
temps de dévier le fou évidemment car ça
ne tombe pas dans le piège et derrière
foulées et les coups gagnants puisqu'il
arrive fou hein le fou blanc va se faire
chasser de la dagonale et le pion va
forcément à la dame regardez on va
illustrer par exemple on prend ici s'il
vous s'en va on va jouer F2 et on fait
dame au coup d'après donc Maxime qui
ouvre le score avec les pièces noires
donc immédiatement ça fait très mal la
seconde partie on va pas s'attarder
dessus puisqu'elle est pas très
intéressante elle était très symétrique
Maxime avec les bombes n'a rien obtenu
et il mène au score donc il lui a raison
derrière il a mis les barbelés il a
assuré la nuit c'est encore montré très
précieux pour pas se faire piéger et on
va basculer directement dans la
troisième partie où ça s'est plutôt mal
passé pour le français dans l'ouverture
c'est vraiment très dans une position
perdante il a donc ici les pièces noires
et regarder un c'est assez monstrueux il
a un pion de moins mais surtout il y a
ces deux pions passé liés qui sont très
proches de la dame et soutenus par ce
fou surpuissant alors maxime a certes un
joli cahier 3 mais malgré cette
avant-poste il ne fait pas grand chose
donc il tape un peu sur du vide et le
pion passé B peine quand même à se
montrer aussi menaçant disons que que
les pions blancs seulement ici car ça
n'a joué F5 qui est le bon coup mais
dans la foulée il a échangé les dames il
a voulu un peu trop assurer alors que
s'il avait gardé les dames par exemple
en jouant E6 vous regardez le roi noir
ça fait quand même très peur on a
beaucoup de colonnes de diagonales qui
s'ouvre donc par exemple tout reprend
ici dame pro F5 maintenant cette fois-ci
les blancs gardent les dames il y a
vraiment trop de menaces de maths de
partout honnêtement le roi ici ne peut
pas survivre le Pione cette menace
d'avancer on peut regarder une
illustration peut-être mettons d'Amel 7
juste pour concentrer si on essaie de
faire un blocus et ici les blancs ils
sont tranquilles ils peuvent juste
manger le pion et dire au noir bah à
vous de jouer qu'est-ce que vous faites
le bras va tranquillement se décaler la
tour va coulisser le pion B peut aussi
partir donc c'est complètement foutu
cette position sauf que Carsen il a
préféré échanger les dames il a pas
voulu rendre de pion et il estimé que
cette finale elle a gagné peut-être
assez facilement pour lui sauf qu'ici
Maxime il a réussi à mettre en place un
incroyable book blocus sur casse blanche
c'est évidemment la seule chance ici
mais il a fallu pour ça un jeu
extrêmement précis je vais avancer un
nouveau rapidement jusqu'à la conclusion
de cette partie maxime a joué une série
de ce coup on va y venir ici sur C2 fou
B2 donc qui empêche le pion noir d'aller
à dames tout F8 c'était le seul moyen il
faut être prêt en fait à abandonner
notre arme ceux pion c'est pour à tout
prix capturer les pions blancs et
ensuite on sera hors de danger sauf que
E6 fait quand même très peur il y a du
E7 du X3 dans l'air Maxime qui va encore
jouer le seul coup cavalier C7 double
attaque alors qu'il a que quelques
secondes à la pendule et ça va aboutir à
une simplification massive tout va
s'échanger Maxime récupère donc les
pions blancs et donc sauve une nul un
peu miraculeuse mais grâce à ses
capacités défensives hors du commun
honnêtement je pense que quasiment aucun
autre joueur au monde aurait pu s'en
sortir dans cette position contre Maxime
contre contre malus grâce à Maxime qui
est maintenant à la mission de ne
simplement pas perdre avec les pièces
blanches dans la quatrième partie pour
remporter donc cette première manche et
il va y réussir très facilement il a
obtenu cette position qui a l'air plutôt
intéressante pour aider avec notamment
cette batterie sur le roi et ici
gardienne il va gaver qui joue H5 pour
parer la menace H4 l'idée d'achat c'est
sur H4 déjà on empêche le pion blanc
d'aller en H5 et le four va pouvoir
reculer en H6 et même si la position
blanc est plutôt agréable tout reste à
faire dans cette partie et ici car un
scène à la place il a joué le mauvais
coup
il a joué apprend B2 et donc il a permis
à Maxime qui a été surpris on a pu voir
à l'image de balancer H4 et si le four
recul il y a tout simplement H5 et cette
batterie et juste terrible pour les
Noirs ils ne peuvent rien faire le pion
G6 va tomber le roi va se faire mater
donc la position ne va pas du tout c'est
pourquoi ici carrassen a préféré
sacrifier le fou mais évidemment ça ne
va pas du tout il n'y a pas assez de
contre jeu la position est objectivement
gagnante pour les blancs par exemple
comme tout rêve 2 et finalement le fait
d'avoir été privé de nos pions ça va pas
nous déranger mais c'est même nous qui
avec les Blancs allons attaquer ce roi
sauf que ici on le rappelle la nul
suffit à Maxime la donc jouer tout
reprend B2 laissant à perpétuel
car c'est un petit peu par humour à
balancer un tour proie à deux
intermédiaire qui ne sert à rien qui a
quand même c'est un peu source de tête
tout le monde tout reprend à deux et
ensuite il délivre le perpétuel et donc
il assume il admet ça des fêtes ici il a
vu qu'il est beau aucune chance de
l'emporter donc il préfère passer à
autre chose ce qui fait donc que Maxime
remporte deux ennemis à un ennemi mais
on voit que c'est même pu faire 3 cette
première manche pas le temps de souffler
des jours après quelques minutes
seulement de pause repartent à l'assaut
et la quinzaine on sent qu'il se chauffe
d'un autre bois il a compris le grand
danger que représentait ce Maxime qui
est dans sa meilleure forme et il va pas
hésiter à lâcher une grosse prépa on a
cette position Maxime allez pièces
noires vous allez voir là une série
extraordinaire c'est la partie la plus
incroyable de cette finale
ça commence par cahier prend B5 déjà il
y a des rock opposés donc on sent que la
position est assez chaotique qui peut se
passer beaucoup de choses donc on est
toujours dans la théorie et prend B5 à 6
on chasse le cavalier cavalier vient se
passer au centre il tape sur le four
fousser cette qui attaque la dame et si
la dame se déplace sur sa seule case
libre en 7 alors on a fondé une pièce et
donc facilement gagnant pour les Noirs
évidemment ce n'est pas idée de car
c'est une qui avait préparé à la maison
ce sacrifice de dames cavalier prend ici
il laisse donc sa dame en prise maxime
n'a pas d'autre choix que de la capturer
la tour reprend elle prend le 6 faut
prendre ces quatre et on fait le bilan
pour la dame et le cavalier il y a
seulement deux fous de pions donc une
dame pour une pièce et deux pions donc
d'un point de vue matériel c'est
écrasant pour les Noirs ce que on voit
que c'est fou sont monstrueux et
l'activité des pièces blanches fait très
peur il y a déjà une menace très directe
de récupérer la dame et les Noirs ont
beaucoup de mal à développer leur pièce
Maxime à admis en interview d'après
partie qui connaissait cette idée cette
prépa mais il avait juste à réviser
vaguement donc il était quand même
relativement livré à lui-même
contrairement à carcène qui avait donc
toutes les cartes en main pour ouvrir le
score dans cette deuxième manche de la
finale un maxime a joué tout revit pour
défendre son pion et après ces 6 on se
rend compte à un point de vue pratique
comme c'est difficile de sortir regarder
cette tour n'a pas de cas ce cavalier
n'a pas de case la dame peut quasiment
pas bouger donc comme c'est difficile de
sortir les pièces noires Maxime prête
tout recettes pour un peu défendre ça
septième rangée fous B6 va jouer le très
bon coup qui est ipt7 il est prêt à
rendre un peu de matériel pour s'activer
et se débarrasser de ce que on sait que
tu es quand même une vraie épine dans la
position noire il ouvre la colonne sur
le noir et essayer de trouver du
contre-jupe on va faire de nouveau une
avance rapide puisque là cette partie
c'est elle mériterait une analyse
évidemment approfondie tellement elle
est compliquée même les ordinateurs ont
du mal à comprendre un certain point il
y a Kevin un Bordy si vous voulez voir
d'ailleurs sur sa chaîne je crois qu'il
analyser cette partie en détail
n'hésitez pas c'est très intéressant on
va passer jusqu'au prochain moment
critique ou ici après G4 Maxime va jouer
d'un MEP 7 il va réussir à trouver du
jeu avec sa dame
c'est sa seule vraie pièce active dans
cette position donc n'hésite pas à s'en
servir très bien vous allez avoir une
nouvelle séquence extrêmement compliquée
et dans cette position car ça ne va
commettre une erreur il doit à tout prix
si manger la tour de Maxime à la base il
va jouer G5 il veut viser le mat à tout
prix avec du cavalier FC qui arrive
potentiellement ouvrir la colonnage
également sur ce roi et en fait sur G5
il a oublié tous ces vide donc on enlève
la tour de la case well attaquer et on
menace dame C7 qui va aller gagner cette
tour blanche donc on part la menace et
on en crée une autre qui est très
puissante et les Noirs ici commencent à
prendre un avantage décisif sauf que
rien n'est fini puisque la position est
beaucoup trop complexe la une nouvelle
séquence ici valait mieux pousser le
pion h pour garder la colonne fermée et
se créer un vrai objectif tout
simplement envoyer spion Adam
maxima était matériel ici la prise G5
et dans cette position comment ça sentir
bon pratique pour les pièces noires
l'impression que les Blancs voilà un
petit peu de mal en terme de
coordination
après notamment ce superbe beaucoup
autour des 8 pour clouer la quinzaine va
trouver le seul coup de Tour Eiffel pour
se défaire du clouage d'en prendre et
jamais possible à cause du mat une sorte
de mettre du couloir
donc maxime a joué dame G2 ici un qui a
un bon coup pratique tour F5 j'ai 620
taquet la tour tour F6 il vient
récupérer un autre pion et là c'est
l'erreur décisive de carcène tu aurais
dû jouer cavalier C6 pour s'en prendre à
la tournoi et essayer de tourner autour
du roi noir mais c'est vraiment très
difficile à jouer surtout avec la
fatigue l'attention et le peu de temps
et après cavalier 3 Maxime joue tour des
trois à cette fois il prend un avantage
décisif ce cavalier il a aucune bonne
case et maintenant les pièces noires
commencent à s'activer et le roi est un
peu moins en danger on va ensuite
obtenir la position suivante
ou
Maxime va de manière très judicieuse
rendre la dame pour simplifier et
transposer dans cette finale facilement
gagnante avec ce pion j'ai passé la
qualité de plus donc il a pas du tout
tremblé il a conclu et donc comme dans
la première manche il l'emporte d'entrée
avec les pièces noir il fait très mal à
carcennes qui se retrouve donc de
nouveau dos au mur à devoir réaliser
l'exploit de Batman sur demande avec les
Noirs dans cette dernière partie du
match maxime a joué un maroxy contre la
nage d'or de Carlsen ça a pas très bien
tourné malgré tout pour le français
puisque cette position elle est plutôt
agréable à jouer pour les pièces noires
ont des quatre
et après les échanges là cette position
ou à juste titre gardienne va échanger
son faux contre le cavalier pour éviter
du cavalier F6 échec admettons que je
passe mon tour juste pour illustrer donc
je joue à une cavalier E3 qui pourrait
être tentant là il y aurait cavalier F6
et en cas de prise et bien vous prend un
chèque et cette fois les pièces blanches
vont s'activer et le roi va se faire
mater le duo dame tour et ici trop
puissant donc c'est une vraie menace
donc car un scène a raison d'échanger
faut prendre un cadre cavalier 3 et là
le bluff incroyable de Maxime qui va
fonctionner alors je dis bluff alors
qu'en réalité peut-être une erreur de
calcul un petit peu des deux hommes mais
voilà c'est vraiment difficile il a
balancé fou prend Hachette il a senti
que la partie commence un peu échapper
il avait du retard à la pendule à la
position était vraiment dans le style de
Magnus qui pouvait presser améliorer
petit à petit il a voulu changer le
cours de la partie et ce choix s'est
avéré payant donc c'était vraiment un
coup psychologique quelque part aussi
Maxime ici donc c'est très bien vu de sa
part d'un point de vue pratique tourage
3 échec droit vient et là à tempo
personnage a joué F5 et le coup raté par
les deux hommes qui gagnaient pour les
Noirs c'était F6 vous allez voir la
nuance tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
sur dame achète échec comme dans la
partie damashait l'échec roi F7 l'idée
de Maxime c'est de jouer tout rachis
donc ça c'est la partie avec une menace
dame G6 échec et dame prend aussi pour
mater en tout cas on va illustrer
cavalier prend tour dame G6 échec donc
si le roi revient mais on fait un
perpétuel qui revient à la victoire pour
Maxime puisqu'il a gagné la première
partie et si le roi va au 7 il y a donc
dame prend aussi échec et mat donc vous
comprenez maintenant peut-être la nuance
pourquoi F6 était nettement plus malin
puisque ici
et ici le coût perdant joué par quinzen
après quand même plusieurs minutes de
réflexion il a joué dame qu'on sait 4 le
bon coup pour continuer le combat
c'était roi E8
il aurait suivi certainement tout
reprend aussi roi des 7 la dame serait
venue en G6 cavalier prend en tour ce
sont des variantes compliquées ici
maxime a beaucoup de retard matériel
si j'ai autour des problèmes c'est qu'il
a quand même peut-être y avoir même
il y a deux tours cavaliers pour la dame
ça risque de faire beaucoup et surtout à
sponder qui est très dangereux
ou peut-être que ici tout reprend B6
c'était plus fort pour pour mener ces
maths rois maintenant mais tout ça va
c'est très ordinateur s on va pas trop
creuser les trois résultats ont été
possible ici mais en tout cas personne
n'aurait clairement conservé des chances
de l'emporter donc au lieu de jouer ça
il a gaffé avec Dame prend ses quatre
dame pro C4
la tête entre les mains Maxime qui n'en
croyait pas ses yeux mais pourtant
l'expo était accompli puisqu'il y a plus
de défense on menace de mater donc tout
reprend F6 et obligatoire eux prend F6
et si on joue cahier des 5 pour Paris
dame de cette map alors tout simplement
F7 et on va faire dames sur échec les
blancs vont se retrouver avec deux dames
et donc une position et bien écrasante
ouais c'est comme ça que Maxime
l'emporté donc 2-0 dans cette deuxième
manche donc on score cumulé ça fait
quand même quatre et demi à 1 et demi
c'est très net il y a aucune défaite du
français cette victoire lui permet au
passage d'arracher son ticket pour
Toronto ou se déroulera la grande finale
du Championship tour donc c'était le
sixième et dernier événement maxime a
arraché le dernier ticket au nez à la
barre de fedoc
et du coup il fera partie des 8
finalistes la phase finale se déroulera
cette fois en présentiel tu vois aussi
fil rouge à carcène Nakamura ça va être
certainement un événement assez
exceptionnel à suivre en décembre
avant cela Maxime disputera le grand
Suisse qui sera autrement plus important
où il tentera d'arracher un des derniers
tickets en jeu pour les candidats son
grand objectif de la saison mais vu la
forme est un centre qui l'affichait ces
dernières semaines avec sa victoire au
tata Céline dia sa performance contre
Naka en demi-finale du speechs qu'il a
dominé jusqu'aux Bullet mais voilà c'est
pas forcément des vrais échecs
et cette victoire contre Carlson en
finale vraiment de très bonne augure
pour les échéances à venir pour Maxime